i mean the mind is like a computer
program and the fact that it's on a
negative loop is because we programmed
it on a negative loop but you know we
could have been influenced when we're
children and things like that one of the
things that the mind loves is love's
repetition i mean loves it you know if
you really watch your thoughts this is
the same old thoughts over and over
again you know it's just kind of dishing
up the same old thing so it loves
repetition so the way you can override a
program is to put in the opposite and
when you start out you feel like you're
lying you'll say something like you
might be really broke i was when i was
making a secret so you might not have
any money and you're trying to instill
wealth and prosperity and riches and
every time you say it you feel a
contraction in your body because you
know you don't have it but you know
truly because i did it myself after a
while you change it you really begin to
change it and you don't quite have that
contraction anymore and then you start
to see money coming in in different ways
um and any and and or you can be given
things that you were going to buy and
now you don't have to buy it or so you
begin to see you start to see signs of
land you know is one of the great one of
the great new thought
thought
writers would say talk about a sign of
land so you start to see sign of land
now that's what i did in the secret you
can do gratitude that will turn
everything around that will make you
feel good that will get you off the
negative right
but those negative thoughts are coming
from beliefs held in the subconscious
mind
right that's where the beliefs stem from
for most of us they stem mostly from our
childhood
conditioning
yeah somebody's our parents said
something to us we just swallowed it
hook line and sinker you know we're like
right that's a belief
and uh and so we take it in and and then
we have all these beliefs that that uh
and you can hear you know if you if
you're talking to somebody like if
if somebody says oh i believe
or because we say that all the time or
somebody says i think
behind those two
behind those two statements are going to
be a belief
and so the really interesting thing
they're hard to spot because you believe
they're true
they seem real yeah so you don't think
yeah you don't think they're a belief
you think they're real you know and so
they can be hard to spot but if you
start to listen to yourself you know i
believe or i think or especially look at
the things that you have a really strong
opinion about
because where you have a really strong
opinion is a belief that's underneath
that
so
so one of the things that in the latest
book is that i show how to
um show how to dissolve those those
beliefs and
just really by some of the things that
i've just mentioned
and uh and and you can dissolve them and
you just feel free every time a belief
goes out you feel completely free
you know it's a it's amazing amazing
feeling
to you just feel as light as a feather
and actually you feel invincible
energy is everything when you're
thinking about a law of attraction and
you need to be coming from a positive
grateful abundant
feeling
in order to start creating more of that
you can't come from a feeling of lack of
scarcity of not enough i don't love
myself if you don't love yourself you're
saying to the world to the universe to
other people
why would i work with you why don't i
connect with you why do i want to be in
love with you if you don't love yourself
so you got to start shifting that way of
thinking the way of feeling the way of
being in order to really show up
energetically around other people one of
my early mentors told me the world makes
room for passionate people
think about it
if you are slunched over every single
day like this lacking confidence
stressed anxious
you know depressed and you're unable to
get out of your own way because you're
constantly thinking
about how much you don't love yourself
i've been there i know this feeling if
you're in that state
people aren't attracted to that they're
attracted to someone who is humble yet
confident at the same time in their
abilities
someone who cares and can look other
people in the eye someone who's got a
big heart and opens up and is is willing
to receive
information not someone who's slouched
over and has
you know a middle finger up to the world
they want people who are open who are
willing who are down to try things who
are passionate at least passionate about
the thing they care about and when you
show your passion about something
people are attracted to energy that is
passionate that is grateful that is fun
that is loving that is expressive that
is creative
that is
expansive they're not attracted
to people who are closed off and guarded
that is not attractive that is not sexy
in any part of life in relationship
health business you're not gonna attract
people from that place so we're working
to reprogram your mind and break the
patterns that have been leading your
life because
i've been there in so many different
areas of my life for many different
years that have held me back and some
i've been confident in certain areas and
others i've lacked confidence and this
is a process and this is a journey and
it's not going to happen overnight when
we talk about
or think about the law of attraction
before we even consider that law and
several other corollary laws
when we talk about everything is energy
what does that really mean
right like what does that really mean
and
when you think about you know we use
telescopes to look into outer space into
the cosmos
and we use microscopes to look deeper
into material things until
it all disappears anyway right
we can see electrons and protons and
muons
and quarks
and leptons the very
fundamental building blocks of nature of
our body of plants of the ocean of
everything
in the
known cosmos and
it appears
that everything is vibrating if you were
to look through these electron
microscopes you know deep into a plant
or even your hand although it appears to
be solid
um we see vibrating packets of this
thing we call energy vibrating packets
of something called quanta right
and so if everything is vibrating
then is it possible and this is a
dialogue right is it possible
that when you and i have
a thought
a positive one a negative one
a thought about something we want or
something we don't want right so it's a
thought a spark of
electrochemical activity
in the brain a thought we say you know i
want this i don't want that is it
possible let's just have a little
dialogue here is it possible
that since that thought
is a burst of electrical activity
and also
releases a chemical that correlates with
that thought
is it possible
that
the
electrochemical activity is vibrating
oscillating moving whatever you want to
call it at a certain frequency
that resonates or repels with certain
things in the physical world is it
possible if everything is
energy
um
how do you get into resonance
with what it is you want to
you know attract how do you get mentally
physically emotionally spiritually in
resonance
with the stuff that you want
instead of what you don't want here's
one of the biggest challenges
our brains are wired for safety first
emotional safety physical safety
financial safety first and so in order
to protect ourselves
our brain actually has to think about
where is there danger
like where could i get hurt and in think
about where you can get hurt is it
possible that
sometimes we're in a temporary or
permanent state of fear
and if we're in a permanent or temporary
state of fear is it possible that that
state of fear or uncertainty or
self-doubt
is actually attracting
resonating with the stuff that we don't
want
one of the keys
to applying the law of resonance um is
getting your
mindset right the brain
right focused on what it is that you
want
getting your heart
right the emotions
aligned as well so it's head and heart
aligned also with what it is you want to
resonate with
and then there's another piece to it
that not a lot of people think about or
talk about and that's the gut
right the brain gut access is in
communication
with each other at all times and there's
a lot of research around you've got to
really follow your instincts right your
intuition your instinctual feeling about
stuff so you got to get the head the
heart and the gut aligned
and that is really the winning
combination to be in a state of
resonance you have to really begin to
mentally rehearse
like so you ask yourself at the end of
your day i do this every day how'd i do
how'd i do today bro how'd you do did
you do good where'd you fall from grace
what what what was it
that caused you to go unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student
of life you'll begin to contemplate well
it was that person that said that thing
then i reacted or this i got this email
or things didn't go my way and i started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens how could i
evolve my experience now you may have to
search for some answers
of the best model to build or you may
actually have a long contemplation and
start to go god the next time that
happens i think i'm going to do this or
i'm going to do that or i'm going to
plan my behaviors
and the act of closing your eyes
and rehearsing what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
hardware in your brain to looks like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the future and if you keep
installing that hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important
than the news right it's more important
than answering any email or any text
it's more important than talking about
your past or some dinner
if you can begin to just
think about how you're going to do it
differently
that's the building process
neurologically already so now you have
to get conscious in order to do that and
it takes some time it means you got to
shut your cell phone off you got to
close your door you got to take a break
from everything out there and begin to
practice and so
by experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear
and now we've given people the tools to
be able to self-regulate to create brain
and heart coherence and so you see
people say excuse me one minute i just
need a minute
it takes some breaths they get back in
they connect to the energy of their
future this is incidental compared to
where they're going so they don't
fall from grace they don't allow their
energy to drop and so yeah in the
beginning
it takes a lot because it takes a lot of
energy and awareness
to stay conscious and not go unconscious
but if you're persistent and you're
determined and you're sincere
you begin to figure it out you begin to
say
i am not going to give my power away to
that person or that circumstance when i
can use it to heal or to create a new
future and so people then
won't excuse themselves and say i had a
hard day yesterday i had a fight with my
co-worker or my ex or and i don't feel
like doing the work well
that's the time to get back on the horse
yeah because because
it's the it's all of those times that we
self-correct
those are the most valuable moments thus
people who've had profoundly
transcendental experiences where they
we say got lit up they connected and
their brain goes into very very high
coherent states and super gamma patterns
that are way outside of normal and they
have a transcendental download or
connection that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past
because it got them to that moment
that's the moment the past no longer
exists now by the same means
they look back at their past
and they see all those tough moments
where they overcame themselves and they
fall in love with that person they don't
look at the good meditations or the
things that went well they look they
know that it was those moments that got
them to this moment and i think then
that's when they begin to understand
that that all of the hard work
all the effort
in who we become makes no one can take
that away from us so then once we arrive
at that level and we experience whatever
the dream is or whatever we create the
next thing is do it until you fully
enjoy it and then when it gets boring or
predictable let's go again let's do
something else
identity is the governor on our lives
it's the invisible force that no one
understands and once they do understand
and get a hold of it their life can
change and so not only if you don't get
a hold of this well these outward
conditions of your life keep being
exactly the same but it's you could
behave differently you could do all the
work out you could be thinking great
thoughts but you are going to get out of
your life
you're going to be the most powerful
force in the world i think is to be
consistent with the concepts ideas and
worth that you hold for yourself you
will get that out of your life what you
will tolerate okay the deeper part of
that is identity and so identity is very
much like a thermostat sitting on a wall
right this is important once that
temperature is set at a certain degree
everything in the world externally can
hit it and you will find a way to get
that temperature so even in this house
let's say it's set at 80 degrees if we
opened up all the doors in cold air just
the worst things in life the blizzard of
life came in the thermostat will kick
the heater on and it will regulate this
room back to 80 degrees the reverse is
also true it's a super hot day great
things are happening in your life it's
getting hotter and hotter and hotter if
you're at 80 degrees that internal
thermostat will find a way over a window
of time to cool your life right back
down to 80 degrees again so the key the
secret key is to be able to shift that
identity 90 100 120. so some of the ways
strategies to do that are are very
simple one is if i let's just say
financially
you're a 200 degree and i'm an 80 degree
if i'm in your proximity over and over
and over and over again you will heat my
identity up somewhere in between mine
and yours to 150 degrees same in fitness
same in everything so the more you can
layer in multiple people the stronger
and stronger that force is so that
changes our thermostat through
association it's a huge huge huge huge
thing people say you are who the five
people you hang around this is why
they adjust your thermostat that's
number one second way you can change
your identity is through doing short
bursts of something in a window of time
you've not done them before and they
change the thermostat temperature
permanently almost like a water line in
the pool so if it's a certain in the gym
certain amount in the gym or a certain
amount of phone calls in your business
or certain amount of appointments you
make a certain amount of money
oftentimes you're never the same again
you've seen this with your own net worth
i've seen it in mind there became a
point where i made a leap and a short
window i was never really the same again
i could go back a little bit but not
back where i was before so it's activity
or successes achievements in short
bursts of time the voice within us that
believes that we are not allowed to be
happy
our card today is speaking to that
i believe i'm worthy of feeling good i
believe i am worthy of feeling good
this is often something that is a belief
system that sounds really nice but it's
actually far from our reality because
many of us have been brought up with the
belief system that we have to
suffer to succeed that we have to feel
pain to have purpose that we have to
have struggles in order to feel a sense
of serenity in our life that is all
quite backwards
it's when we feel good that we actually
attract more of what we want into our
life but we have to undo the belief
system that says who am i to feel good
who am i to feel great who am i to be
happy that belief system is an ingrained
belief system that can be cultural that
can be something that we learned from
our upbringing it can be something that
we have picked up from this difficult
experience that we're going through
right now with kovid when we witness
people suffering we think well how how
dare i be happy i would say to you how
dare you not be happy it's your
happiness it's the collective happiness
it's the group
collective happiness that raises the
energetic frequency of the world if we
those of us who have moments of
happiness and grace and joy and success
and we don't celebrate them we are doing
the world a disservice we are shutting
down the light we are bringing down the
vibration so we have to when we feel
good we have to reach for more when we
feel good we have to recognize that that
good feeling emotion
has momentum it has power it elevates
our children it elevates our family
members it elevates our friends it
elevates strangers on the street it is
your divine duty here on earth to bring
forth that greatness that goodness that
light so when you hear that voice that
says to you you are not worthy of
feeling good i want you to hear my voice
come through and say to you who are you
not to feel good
this is your divine purpose it is your
mission and it is the way that you heal
and serve you got me
we are more comfortable being
uncomfortable than we are being happy
so when things are good and when we
start to get a sense of feeling good
our ego the voice of fear within us
starts to say hell no too good to be
true and it will find these weird little
corners to pick up problems
we have a fault-finding mindset rather
than a solution happiness-oriented
mindset so when that happens the next
time you notice that you're feeling good
and all is well and all of a sudden
you're like but i wasn't nice enough to
that person or my co-workers aren't in a
good place or i didn't do that right
i want you to speak back to that voice i
want you to say thank you for sharing
but i choose happiness instead
thank you for sharing but i don't
believe that voice anymore thank you for
sharing but i'm choosing this moment
give yourself permission in the moment
to speak back to the fault-finding voice
and start to claim the greatness of who
you are that is a pattern because you've
lived your life in a habitual pattern of
seeking problems and finding fault now
we have to redirect and create a new
habit and pattern of grounding you in
the truth of who you are which is
happiness joy peace and
grace sharing that happiness joy and
peace with so much grace
that's what you're here for
i used to struggle a lot with
manifesting just the idea of it i would
watch videos on it and i didn't
understand what they were saying i
didn't i just didn't understand it uh
well there's manifest in a lot of
attractions like what are they saying i
don't understand the words that are
coming out of your mouth and i would
rewind and watch again it's like i don't
get it i don't understand i don't i
don't understand and it seemed
weird silly
not good enough for me to just sit on a
couch and think about money coming into
your wallet or
whatever it was that you're trying to
manifest you got to go do something that
in law of attraction
you know action is at the end of
attraction like you got to go off and
and do the work if that's been you have
you been kind of struggling with
manifesting
or law of attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and it
feels too woo-woo for you
let me uh let me let me explain it from
a different perspective and and maybe
it'll help at least this is what's
helped me the first thing that i
realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems as part of your brain
that decides what to pay attention to
and what to not pay attention to there
there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out
your the job of the reticular activating
system you can go look it up ras
is to filter out most things and only
filter in the things that you should
care about so for example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know i didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the
the sign here you're looking at the
driveway you're looking to cuddle the
sky you're looking at the house you look
at the what material that might be
you're not looking at anything again
it's too blurry you're still looking at
my face you're looking at my car you're
looking at the color of the headrest
you're looking at my outfit like what
are you paying attention to most things
you're
ignoring because there's no possible way
to pay attention to everything
potentially the dog just anna
hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you that's just
impossible be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right i want to pay attention
to x and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often i i'm i
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things i noticed
was the for sale sign here where i may
have not noticed that as much
in the past but because thinking house
boom now i'm paying attention to the for
sale sign you ever notice when you buy a
car you start seeing that car everywhere
right you're even thinking about buying
a car you're thinking about buying an x
you start seeing it on the street more
often
why that's your reticular activating
system basically saying
i want to pay attention to those things
so that car was still around right i
mean i i got this car we've got a
porsche
and now i see porsches more often those
porsches still existed they were they
were already there i just didn't notice
them before and now i notice them
because i have one right um so whatever
it is that you want
whatever it is that you're sending
intention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car new house or business growth or you
speaking on stage or whatever your goals
are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it
right we are we we consistently think
about when you start thinking about it
you'll start seeing opportunities around
you that were already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
i
judged myself too harshly for the ideas
that i came up with
and as soon as i came up with an idea i
was like oh you can't do that or i had
to have the perfect plan before i would
ever take any kind of action on it and
you know just later realize that
you can never plan all the way out
there's no way you know if you wait to
have the perfect plan by the time you
start actually executing the plan is
is dead it's over um
and so you have to trust in your ideas
and so the thing that
really helped me is
i believe that great ideas flow through
me
believe that great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you shortcut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in
you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not i
wanna i wanna go
you're you're in a jealous rage or
you're angry
don't trust your ideas then
but when when you're positive and
optimistic and bold and courageous and
an idea comes to trust that that's the
right idea for you just trust it it's
the right and then go do something about
it where normally what we do is we
overthink and we over plan and over
prepare and then we lose the momentum
and then the next day or the next week
or the next month it's gone it's over
he's like oh i can't do that no that was
actually a great idea for you and it's
happened enough to me
where those things have worked out
where i come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically
but
i just decide to listen to it and do
something on it and it leads to
something amazing
the amount of times that that's happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me i had to see it you know i had to
see it enough times come up because i
wouldn't just believe it on faith i had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive state you know put on a happy
song
move around a little bit and then notice
your thoughts and where it's going and
what you want to create or who you want
to reach out to what you want to do like
what what thought comes to mind after
you're moving around and having some
positive energy that's probably the
right thing for you and just test it out
by doing something about it and maybe
that's a business idea maybe that's an
email you need to send maybe that's a
friend you need to reach out to
maybe that's an act of kindness that you
need to do whatever the thing is that
pops into your mind trust those ideas
and and you could be a scientist like
i'm i like data and i like science and i
like just i like proving things
maybe i'm a skeptic i don't know but
in running those experiments i i proved
to myself that yeah great ideas
do flow through me
and so the next time i have a great idea
i'm gonna go
and take action on it
so number one reticular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards it you start seeing it
like you notice a new car
uh when you buy your new car you see
that car everywhere and then number two
is trust that good ideas flow through
you
number three is the one that i'm working
on that i'm i'm having
the hardest time with and i
i
believe it and i'm trying to
i'm in the process of getting better at
it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that
a lot of the manifestation a lot of
attraction people talk about but also
people like grant cardone talk about it
uh that is it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened
that it's not going to happen in the
future but that it's already happened
you know if your goal is to speak on
stage then you're visualizing and you're
telling yourself i am
i am on stage i am speaking to
i am speaking to a million people or
that's that's that's a giant stadium
i am speaking to
70 000 people you know i am i am the
author of a best-selling book uh i am
like whatever your goal is and
what i think the point of that is
is yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things uh two to not have a be so
far away that it lets you off the hook
for taking action but i think most
importantly is for you to feel what it
feels like to be that
and the more you feel like it feels like
to be that the more it actually becomes
true
if your goal is to speak on stage in
front of 5 000 people
and you
actually feel like you're doing it you
can visualize yourself being on stage
and doing it
the goal i think i'm still working
through this so one and two i've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and there's 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you
and the more that's going to show up
does that make sense so whatever it is
that you are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that
you imagine yourself already having done
it
and this is probably not something that
i would tell other people you know like
oh yeah i'm a i'm uh you know i'm a
speaker in front of 70 000 people
because
because i haven't spoken at a stadium
that big
but
to yourself at least
to
say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay i am i am healthy
but look i've got i've got a belly or
i've got a you know whatever i'm i'm i'm
i am healthy i am healthy and
visualizing yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like
you are healthy and you capture that
feeling the more frequently you're in
there the more likely it's going to show
up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and i'm still
working my way through it as well so as
i keep getting better and keep learning
i'll keep sharing with you but
i used to think like
manifestation law of attraction was way
out there stuff that that i judged and
that i didn't understand and that didn't
make any sense like just go off and take
action guys
and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um
using the reticular activating system to
notice things around me
by trusting that great ideas flow
through me and following through and
building momentum
and by
talking to myself in the present moment
as if
i am that person that i want to become
so i can capture that feeling and know
what it feels like to be that person
i've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life and business
and i hope it can work for you too so if
you take
any event that's occurred in the past if
you just merely think of that event
that's occurred in the past chances are
you're firing off the neural network of
that pattern
right so you can take um uh the idea of
eating your favorite dessert what do you
think is happening in your brain when
you pretend you're eating that favorite
dessert of yours and your mouth starts
to water and you start to feel oh that's
such a great dessert that's neurons in
your brain firing in the neurochemistry
that is associated with that memory
firing now
let's say
that you have a
disempowering pattern of being
embarrassed or ashamed or ridiculed but
instead of just thinking about the
pattern oh i don't like it as soon as
you think about the pattern
and it has a i'm going to say a
disempowering or negative emotion
chances are that means that the stress
center in the brain has been activated
that means that your heartbeat is going
to go up that means that your sweat
glands are going to be activated that
means you're going to breathe a little
bit less
deeply you're going to be more shallowly
and that is the fear or stress response
now what if
instead of allowing that to continue
you just stopped
and you had this intention
i'm going to dissolve
the effectiveness or the strength of
this pattern how do you do that well
first and foremost you stop you sit
and you start with inner size number one
that actually i guide you through
in the book
all right and inner size number one
is called take six calm the circuits so
you wanna move from your stress and
react system
to your relax and respond system you
have
parasympathetic and sympathetic nervous
systems okay that are triggered within
the body so what happens when you sit
quietly and you take six deep breaths in
through your nose
and out through your mouth like you're
blowing out through a straw when you do
it six times in ten second rhythmic
breaths
and you focus
on the air that you're blowing out
through your mouth like you're blowing
out through a straw that simple inner
size
is inner size number one take six calm
the circuits it actually
deactivates the stress
fear embarrassment shame guilt circuit
and in a quiet relaxed state
that same memory does not have the same
power
but if you don't do it in that state you
do it in a in a tense stressful state
you're actually reinforcing that pattern
versus thinking about bringing up that
old memory
and doing this repetitively
10 times 20 times 30 times 40 times
until the neurons really don't fire that
strength at that strength level i think
we're all faced with great opportunities
brilliantly disguised as impossible
situations
and in order like for me personally and
i and after looking through your book
and reading a good portion of it i mean
for me there's there's no school
of ancient wisdom that you need to go to
to be initiated your life is your
initiation if you're paying attention so
we meet challenges in our life from a
certain level of mind right a certain
level of consciousness or
unconsciousness and even einstein said
we have to go to a greater level of
consciousness
than the consciousness that's created
the problem what is consciousness
consciousness is awareness
and awareness means possibilities that
you haven't thought of before
so
we confront problems or challenges in
our life and as a side note
i was having breakfast with a researcher
just last week
who's studying what happens when we
perceive a condition in our environment
as a problem how it weakens the organism
they're measuring this and when a person
sees it as a challenge how they draw
energy they raise the energy of their
body back into order
so
if we said i want to be
wealthy or i want to be healthy
well what but you want to be that
because you're not it
so the initiation of going from not it
here to it here you're going to have to
climb some steps and there's going to be
some blind spots so you try it out and
it doesn't work
well that's because there's a part of
you that's still in a habit there's part
of you that's still unconscious okay so
what is it about myself and that
circumstance
that i am feeling
about that circumstance and that feeling
is causing me to think about it so you
say oh it's impossible they'll never
change i'll hire a hitman i'll hire the
mafia i'll hire an attorney i'll have my
friend's friend to talk to him and
nothing changes right well
you're not you're not separate
from that experience you're involved in
it and how you think and how you feel
broadcasts energy into the field so your
energy is the same every day and as long
as your energy is the same nothing's
going to change in your life either and
nobody changes until they change their
energy so then
what piece of knowledge
what piece of information what would
love do what would greatness look like
okay i don't know
all right well certainly somebody in
history has faced this problem
don't get on facebook and say does
anybody have any answers don't get
go look it up and study and read and
learn you'll own it and you'll say wow
that person that was wealthy
they failed 500 times
well hell i had the wrong view of wealth
okay then failure is not a thing i got
to overcome failure well yep just climb
the step yeah okay i'm reacting to that
circumstance with the same emotion that
emotion is firing the same thoughts i'm
broadcasting the same energy into the
field
if i were facing that circumstance and
situation again with that person that
circumstance what do i learn from that
circumstance how could i do it
differently the next time
find out a solution and rehearse it
install the circuitry so when you get in
the circumstance you're not going to
respond in an automatic habituation yeah
now you're at a greater level of
consciousness now you're looking at
possibilities that you weren't looking
at before because you were unconscious
now
that process of trial and error is so
important in the spiritual path
how many times
do we have to forget before we remember
and then we remember and we forget again
and it takes constantly remembering
until we stop forgetting and when we get
to that point now we're conscious
now there's wisdom and wisdom is the
memory
of the experience without the emotional
charge now you're ready for the new
adventure so then
people draw conclusions and say oh it's
that person that ripped me off as that
person that
what now now you don't create your
reality you only create reality when
things are good
well somehow you got to tango through
this somehow your objectivity in not
reacting emotionally
is going to change the energy of how you
address this situation when i was small
mom i was also really undersized so it's
probably one of the reasons i lift
weights i was always the every baseball
picture on the kid holding the sign in
the front right so i was small and
skinny uh they used to tease me eddie
spaghetti you know and i'd get bullied
at school and i never retaliated so i
had that mixed with shyness mixed with
chaos in my home which many people can
relate to and i gotta tell you that the
shift for me sports was good for me
because it gave me an out that i finally
found something that i was pretty good
at
i think the biggest shift in our lives
the things that makes us the happiest is
that when somebody helps us identify our
natural giftedness
and when i was a little boy when i got a
little bit older they pointed out my
speed
so it wasn't my lack of size i was fast
i was the best kid right i always wanted
to be fast kid and i got confidence in
baseball doing that when i got into
business i said you know you're intense
when someone points out a gift about you
that you also kind of intuitively know
to be true
they're linked to them you're intense
you're passionate you won't get out work
you're relentless i want i am those
things and when someone linked those
gifts to me winning now i believed i
could win that's the other way to change
identity is when someone can link your
giftedness to the victory you'll believe
it not like you're great that's general
that's [ __ ] but it's something you
know specific like for you right now
you wouldn't brag about there's a few
things you know you know what i am good
at these things right i've always been
good at these things it's natural for me
and when someone links that to you
winning like for you for example you're
an unbelievable interviewer you have
this general
you you don't need to be the smartest
person in the room because you probably
are most of the time and so there's a
confidence no there's a confidence that
allows you to be present when you
interview me and just listen that's
different than anyone who's interviewed
me before and so that's a natural
giftedness for you which is why there's
a part of you that kind of knows i am
pretty you wouldn't say it but i am
pretty good at this this is a good
program and so the way we change our
identity the way i changed mine was by
getting in touch with what some of my
natural gifts were and then using them
in my career using them in my life that
shifted the weight right off of me
because the weight was i suck i'm shy
i'm small i have a screwed up family
that's the weight right the lifting off
of the weight is these are some gifts
god gave me or the universe gave me or
that at least i know i have and i can
spend my life using these gifts now i've
got hope now my identity is changing now
my life takes a different direction when
the fear signal has kicked in
all right it's releasing the
neurochemicals like i said epinephrine
cortisol norepinephrine which is
adrenaline
and some of it's good
too much of it will cause you to fight
to freeze
to flee run away or to faint those are
the four
okay possible outcomes for the stress
response or fear response system when it
kicks in so when that switch is turned
on think of it as a light switch that
just turned on in your brain and then
there's a cascade
okay of neurochemicals that causes a
feeling if you focus on the feeling then
you're going to think about what you
feel then you're going to feel what you
think about you create the
self-fulfilling doom loop of
neurochemicals being rushed in your body
and if you do that every day every week
every month over and over again you've
now just set up a doom loop habit where
that fear is going to drive your
thoughts and emotions and behaviors or
lack thereof but what i want you to do
is recognize the fear
calmly
and you do this as soon as you recognize
the fear that you can bring up on your
own you do the first inner size okay
inner size exercise for your physical
body and your organs inner size for your
neuro muscles all right so
when you feel fear
be in observation of it like the light
comes on in the dash of your car and
then what you do is you take 60 breaths
but here's how you do it
in through your nose out through your
mouth like you're blowing out of a straw
so it goes like this
six breaths
ten seconds each ready
deep rhythmic breaths in up to the lungs
expand the diaphragm so you get the
diaphragm and the lungs expanding
and you breathe out like you're
breathing through a straw so you focus
the energy
out
through the mouth it causes your brain
to actually get
oxygenated
and guess why you want that well when
we're in a state of fear we activate
okay the vagus nerve which constricts
your blood flow it slows down your
heartbeat it causes shallow breathing so
as soon as you
alternate from that fear and stress
response system to the calm
i'm sorry from the from the stress and
react system to the calm and respond
system
your brain shuts off the fear circuit
and activates
the left prefrontal cortex and when you
can think because blood flows back there
again so if fear is holding you back
there's nothing wrong with fear
but there just
may be
um
a lack of skill of knowing
when or what to do does this make sense
so far does this make sense so far so
when you take those six deep rhythmic
breaths
that is what deactivates that stress
response system in the brain and
activates the relax and respond you want
to be in a responsive state
as much as possible
versus a reactive state i think uh you
know if we everything starts with a
thought i mean everything that you do in
your life you you have to have a thought
before you initiate an action right so
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
like any great leader in history
understands that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide are you going to be
defined by a vision of the future
or are you going to live by the memories
of the past so give you an example
most people wake up in the morning
and your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact of everything you've
learned and experienced to this moment
right it's a it's a memory bank
so most people wake up in the morning
and they start thinking about their
problems and those problems are
connected to certain people and things
at certain times and places and the
moment they start start turning on those
circuits those memories are actually
causing them to think in the past
every single one of those memories has
an emotion associated with them and
emotions are the end product of past
experiences
so then the moment they recall the event
or the they recall some problem in their
life they start feeling unhappy they
start feeling discouraged they start
feeling anxious now thoughts of the
language of the brain and feelings of
the language of the body and how you
think and how you feel creates your
state of being so we could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past well if you live in the familiar
past then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future so what
happens for most people is they get
stuck in their biology so think about
this
your body is your unconscious mind it
doesn't know the difference between an
experience in your life that creates an
emotion and an emotion that you can
create by thought alone so if you're
living by the same emotion every single
day and those emotions are influencing
your thoughts and you can't think
greater than how you feel or feelings
have become the means of thinking you're
thinking in the past your lens of the
future is going to be colored by the
past so you can't see possibilities so
most people like to wait for crisis or
disease or diagnosis before they wake up
yes enough to see well the challenge is
is that biology tends to be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those thoughts begin to fire certain
circuits in your brain the nerve cells
that fire together wire together so all
of a sudden you start getting hardwired
and those are the thoughts that you can
think the easiest at the same time those
thoughts produce chemicals called
emotions and the next thing you know
your body gets accustomed to living by
the same emotions and it could be guilt
it could be unhappiness it could be pain
but at least it's familiar to you at
least you can predict it so some people
would rather cling to the familiar than
take a chance and possibilities so
for most people then they say well
i don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because
95 of those thoughts are subconscious
programs right so you're not even
conscious that you think those thoughts
so the first step to change
is starting to think about what you've
been thinking about and change it and
and when you begin to observe those
thoughts you're no longer the program
you're the consciousness observing just
simply by being an observer of your
thoughts right so so though so most
people though when they when you do that
when you decide to really take a look
it's like lighting a match in a dark
place
so you feel uncomfortable so it's easier
to turn on your tv it's easier to
play with your cell phone to distract
yourself from those feelings well when
you understand that change really
requires becoming uncomfortable to a
certain degree and that's normal that
you're leaving the known and you're
stepping into the unknown
then it begs the question what thoughts
do you want to fire and wire in your
brain because your attention on those
thoughts begins to reorganize circuitry
re-mold the brain here's the hard truth
about getting great
it takes time and dedication
it takes a willingness to accept that
you're not yet good enough it takes the
ability to stare at the places that you
know that you're weak to really look at
those things and not let it affect your
sense of self-esteem and not let it
affect your sense of self-worth so that
you can still get the momentum going but
you have to understand that in the
beginning
we're all terrible
and as henry cartier-bresson said
your first ten thousand photographs are
your worst
and so the thing that really makes great
art are the people that continue to push
and the people that continue to work and
face how inadequate they are and really
understand that at the end of the day
greatness is a craft greatness is a
process
greatness
is a habit greatness is the little
things that you do every day over time
going out every day unafraid of whether
or not this is one of the 10 000
terrible things that you're gonna do
it's being unafraid to make those
mistakes is being unafraid
that you're not yet great
and as marianne radmaker said
courage doesn't always roar
sometimes
courage is the quiet voice at the end of
the day saying
i will try again tomorrow
and that's it
if you want to be great that's what you
have to do you've got to get up again
tomorrow you've got to be willing to
face another day you've got to be
willing to accept that you've got to get
through the bad ideas before you can get
to the good you've gotta understand that
you have to start as an apprentice you
have to start as a person going and
getting t and you have to accept that
that's the job that you should be
playing that you should be working for
somebody else you should be looking up
to somebody else's seeing what they can
teach you because what you know
is that you're there to learn what you
know is that you're there to get through
the 10
000 bad photographs that you need to get
through to ultimately achieve greatness
and if you make the catastrophic error
that so
many
make
to try to tell the world that you're
extraordinary today to try to get the
world to follow you and look up to you
and think that you're something
today
because the people that really win are
the ones that invest
today the ones that listen today the
ones that spend every ounce of their
energy amassing mastery getting better
every day working their asses off to
improve their skill set to relentlessly
look at the things that they're not
doing well to understand that they have
to break themselves down and get rid of
all of their ego before they can really
find
greatness those are the people that we
remember
so if you want to be remembered
if you want to achieve real greatness
you just need to have the courage to
show up every day
and take another swing
take another photo
try another task
do something that scares you
and do those little things over and over
and over
until you win
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen
in a future video because
you are awesome if you want to see my
one-on-one with naveen check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there
self-belief comes from self-love like
the minute you fall in love with
yourself is the day the world will fall
in love with